there is a campaign to be Donald Trump's
vice president going on right now
and there is really one person who is in
that campaign and it is radical
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene Marjorie Taylor
green is openly running to be Trump's VP
she is trying to dissuade people like
Ron DeSantis and when it looked like
maybe Carrie Lake would be the next
governor of Arizona Kerry Lake from
running
partially because she wants to be
Trump's VP she believes her best shot at
being the vice presidential pick is if
Donald Trump is the nominee and we're
going to get that in a moment Marjorie
Taylor green yesterday was confronted
with a very good question a very obvious
question if Trump is so strong if Trump
is so powerful if Trump is so revered in
the Republican party why did so many of
the people that Donald Trump endorsed
lose and Marjorie Taylor green just sort
of like with a throw everything at the
wall and see if any of it makes sense
answer listen to how she answered the
question Trump endorsed candidates
I would say there's I would say it
depends on the district I think there's
a lot of varying factors
redistricting happened and that was
based on the the census that was pretty
much pre-covered a lot of people moved
out of those districts over the past two
years okay so let's so
oh my goodness so first of all
redistricting only matters in
Congressional races
Trump's biggest losses in the contested
races of consequence that would have
made a difference
Kerry Lake in Arizona that's the entire
State redistricting doesn't matter Blake
Masters in Arizona Senate races are the
entire State redistricting doesn't
matter
um Doug mastriano and Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania Tudor Dixon in Michigan
these are all Statewide races
redistricting doesn't matter then
Marjorie Taylor green pulls well a lot
of people move during the pandemic to
other states unless you can make the
case that it was disproportionately
Republicans that moved that also isn't
really a good explanation for why
Trump's endorsements ended up falling
flat none of these explanations make
sense but remember
Marjorie Taylor green is desperate to be
Trump's VP so she has to come up with
something other than you know a lot of
people kind of don't like Trump I think
that plays the part
um I think it's candidate by candidate
sometimes one campaign has run really
well and sometimes one is not but I
would also say the media plays a big
part ah so then we get to really just
blame the media the media leans pretty
hard left and so when Republican
candidates when we run for office not
only are we running against a Democrat
opponent we're also running against the
media a good bit of the time and that's
really not fair so I think there's a lot
of factors at play and president Trump's
win record uh is is historic most of his
candidates won very few of his
candidates lost yeah and again remember
even Republicans are admitting to the
absurdity of that statement Trump's
record which he says oh we were like 215
or something
every day it's a different number that
he claims you mostly endorse incumbents
who usually win
or Republicans in safe red races
that is not impressive if I was in the
endorsement game
I could have a really good endorsement
record because there are quite literally
hundreds of races in which it's obvious
who's going to win would it really be
meaningful would it really be meaningful
if I actually called it in that way
because I hate to say it a couple
chimpanzees could probably call most of
the races where it mattered where it was
contested where it could have made a
difference in the balance Trump failed
miserably someone who also failed
miserably in their endorsements is Tulsi
gabbard and after the break we're going
to talk a little bit about that